we at GameSpot have compiled a list of
58 quick tips you need to know for apex
legends here we go all characters move
at the same speed holster your weapon to
run faster larger legends have bigger
hip boxes than smaller ones you can use
heal items while sliding down hills you
can ping locations on both the map and
through the ping wheel this symbol means
this person will be the jumpmaster if
you ping an empty attachments on your
inventory your hero will request that I
need a standard started you can block
doors you can kick open block doors with
two melee attacks or you can throw a
grenade at it you can kick if you jump
in melee or melee attacks do the same
amount of damage though Lu ticks are
these things and they carry rare items
they also make a chirping noise so you
know in your near 1 bloodhounds I of the
all-father can highlight these as well
throw grenades into smoke you can peek
over a ledge there's no fall damage but
you can fall off the edge of the map so
be careful upon landing do a melee
attacks you can cancel the splat
animation it's usually not worth doing
an execution down hill sliding speed
stacks with other abilities such as
bloodhounds ultimate or Bangalore's
passive reverse directions on a zipline
by jumping and reattaching in the
opposite direction if you're getting
shot at while zipping up balloons spin
around the rope to get extra evasion if
a down enemy is facing you they are
probably pinging you that means you
should either kill them or run from them
diversify your pings there are many
different commands in the ping wheel be
mindful of bullet drop most sniper
scopes can help you compensate the
Prowler sucks unless you have the select
fire receiver then it's very good
ammo stacks up to a certain point be
efficient if you have a stack of four
bullets you should probably drop it
standard care packages are the only way
to get the crater 50 Cal sniper in the
Mastiff shotgun if you're using the
devotion or havoc be on the lookout for
turbo chargers those make the wind-up
significantly shorter gold armor items
have bonus perks gold helmet speeds up
ability recharge rates the digital
threat can see through smoking gas the
gold knock down shield can perform a
self revive and remember if you knock
someone down with a gold knock down
shield kill them quick because they can
get back up and screw you over later
Gold body shields gets you an automatic
shield recharge when you use a finisher
gold backpack means healing items take
half as long our stars are good at
disorienting enemies and thermite
grenades are good for Zoning teammates
can use your knockdown shield as cover
if you are downed you can't run through
caustics gas even if it's a teammates
bloodhound can see through gas and smoke
with their ultimate lifeline care
packages are blue and red standard care
packages are white and red also lifeline
packages don't carry any weapons make
sure to give your ultimate accelerants
the lifeline she'll thank you I promise
Mirage decoys can activate caustic traps
lifeline can use healing items quicker
when Mirage decoys take damage they
reveal the location of whoever damaged
them with Wraith you can warn your
teammates if someone is aiming at you
you can crawl through Rafe's portals
even if you are downed you can ping
bloodhounds tracks to tell your
teammates more information bloodhounds
tactical ability only works in front of
them remember is Wraith you can still
climb buildings and walls in the void
you can also follow other wraiths into
the void and don't forget to pay
attention to the shadows in the void
those tell you how far you can travel
before you get kicked back to reality
maximize lifelines healing by dropping
the ball first and shield cell recharge
at the same time also make sure to do
that for other teammates as well because
it's just nice you can still smoke while
reloading as Banglore you can trigger
caustic traps by shooting them and
that's it that's all 58 tips we have if
there's any more you know of leave them
in the comments below thank you so much